this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out Squarespace
through the link below
the United Nations today it is the
largest organization in the world nearly
every country on earth is a member and
it's core the UN is a simple yet
remarkably profound concept A place
where Sovereign Nations can settle
disputes with each other into the
battlefield not too long ago however the
U.N was nothing more than an idea and an
office building in New York City what
helped turn it into the powerful force
it is today was the leadership of its
second Secretary General darg hamashold
plucks from his obscure Swedish cabinet
post had placed in the chair of the
world's most powerful Diplomat Hamish
gold hit the ground running guiding the
infant organization into maturity
navigating treacherous Cold War politics
and staring down some of the world's
most powerful leaders he was an enigma
loved by many yet understood by very few
one thing was very clear to everyone
however dark Hamish gold was a man
entirely committed to the ideals of the
United Nations to the idea of world
peace so much so that in the end it cost
him his life
[Music]
in early 1953 the United Nations was in
crisis the body's first Secretary
General the Norwegian trigly had
resigned in November 1952 and the
security Council was gridlocked and
unable to choose his replacement by this
point the United States and this Soviet
Union were locked into a high-stakes
chess game known as the cold war that
saw the two Global superpowers resorting
to every trick short of nuclear war to
try and gain an edge on each other since
they were both members of the security
Council they each held a veto power over
the council's decisions meaning that any
candidate to replace lie that o was
considered too close to one side was
rejected by the other months of gridlock
led to some worry for the future of this
new diplomatic organization if the
superpowers couldn't even agree on
someone to run it the U.N was surely
doomed to failure just like the League
of Nations two decades earlier what was
needed was a compromise candidate
someone that offended neither East nor
West it just happened that Anthony Eden
the British foreign secretary knew Dog
hammershkold a obscure 48 year old
Swedish government Minister who had
enjoyed a successful if unremarkable
career in Sweden's civil service with
everyone running out of ideas who to
appoint Eden suggested him to the UK's
representative on the security Council
the U.S and the Soviet Union barely knew
who hamashkold was and believed him to
be a harmless bureaucrat perfect for
their purposes on March 31 1953 the
security Council voted in favor of
Hamish gold becoming the new Secretary
General of the UN a nomination that was
confirmed without a fuss by the general
assembly the oddest part of the whole
Affair was that nobody in New York had
bothered to ask Hamish gold if it'd be
interested in the job that simply wasn't
the time the first he heard about the
nomination was when he received a phone
call from a journalist in the middle of
the night right after the vote occurred
he believed it to be an April Fool's Day
joke and angrily hung up the phone but a
few hours later an official cable came
from New York asking him to accept the
job Amish gold was flabbergasted having
never shown any interest in the job
prior to that moment in fact during a
conversation with the painter Beau
Basquez some weeks before he had reacted
strongly to Presque is assertion that he
would be a good candidate for the post
saying nobody is crazy enough to propose
me and I would be crazy to accept after
Consulting with the Swedish government
though he felt as though he couldn't
refuse the call to serve his fellow man
even if he felt completely unqualified
to step out onto the world stage a week
later he was sworn in and he took up the
mantle of U.N Secretary General at the
United Nations building in New York City
his nomination would prove to be one of
the most impactful decisions of the 20th
century
[Music]
one of Hamish Gold's first tasks was to
reform the administrative staff of the
UN the Secretariat under his leadership
it would grow to some 4 000 diplomats
who were asked to leave their personal
and national interests at the door in
favor of the cause of the United Nations
how much gold knew that failure to put
National considerations aside in favor
of the common good had been the primary
failure of international peacekeeping
efforts going all the way back to the
Congress of Vienna in 1815. for the U.N
to be successful in its mission to
prevent conflict he needed to create an
entirely new class of international
civil servants who were recruited from
all over the world in this he was
assisted by a group of advisors that
became close friends including a Ralph
Bunch who received the Nobel Peace Prize
for successfully negotiating an end to
the first arab-israeli war in 1949.
Hamish gold was a perfect example of
this new philosophy while never
forgetting where he had come from he had
embraced his new role wholeheartedly he
was a workaholic who subsisted on little
sleep and few Creature Comforts his
apartment was described in terms that
included monastic and Spartan he was
also something of an enigma to New York
Society they had trouble understanding a
man whose only interests outside of his
work appeared to be an appreciation for
Fine Arts and literature as well as the
outdoors he never married he had no
children needing some to speculate that
he was secretly homosexual usually his
detractors attempting to smear his
reputation at a time when being gay was
a career Ender but there's no evidence
that dark Hamish gold had any sexual
Liaisons with anybody bail or female
either because he was asexual or because
like a monk he chose to willingly
abstain from it in favor of larger
Pursuits all right we'll get back to our
video in just a second but first here's
a word from today's sponsor Squarespace
this is the age of creation think about
it everyone is out there you know you
know you're no longer just looking at
stuff on the internet often you're
making it yourself whether that's social
media YouTube your own blog online store
whatever whenever you want to make
something on the Internet and it needs a
website and this thing on YouTube
channel or whatever oh you want a
website to go along with that don't you
well whenever you do want to make a
website head over to our friends at
Squarespace they make it incredibly easy
to take what's in your mind and put it
on the screen in front of you like maybe
they're hands on time you've got lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly
your site should look like well that's
cool Squarespace gives you all of the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
Technic or BS to worry about or maybe
you just need something functional
something that worked so you know you
could just get started with whatever
you're doing on your website in that
case just use one of their quick
beautiful templates and once you're done
setting up the website choosing the name
playing with the colors Etc Squarespace
provide a ton of extra features so that
your site can Thrive patronage portals
email campaigns social Integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
options 200 customer support and more is
everything you could ever want in one
place so when you're ready to get
started the next project of yours big or
small it evolves a website do it
Squarespace go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch your new site go to
squarespace.com slash biographics to
save 10 of your first purchasable
website or a domain and let's get back
into it
in July 1956 the president of Egypt
Gamal Abdul Nassar surprised the world
when he announced that he was
nationalizing the Suez Canal buying it
out from British and French owners NASA
hoped to use the revenue from the canal
to finance the Aswan High Dam which
would end the annual flooding of the
Nile and allow for infrastructure
improvements that would help the
Egyptian economy Great Britain oh is
already not coping well with the sudden
and Rapid loss of its Empire and the
loss of the canal seemed to be another
hit to their Prestige Anthony Eden now
the Prime Minister saw NASA as
threatening not just the established
order but the economic security of all
of Europe since the Suez Canal was the
transit point for most of the oil trade
Eden brought together the governments of
France who believed NASA was providing
arms to Algerian rebels in North Africa
and Israel who saw Egypt as an
existential threat that needed to be
checked and together the three nations
agreed to a secret plan Israel would
invade Egyptian territory advancing
across the Sinai desert after the
Egyptian Military responded the British
and French acting as peacemakers would
call for a ceasefire and demand that
Egypt allow anglo-french troops to
occupy the Suez Canal Zone under the
pretext of keeping it open for
international traffic oh where NASA
naturally refused the British and French
would invade and take the canal by force
hopefully causing the Egyptian people to
turn on NASA and removing from Power the
conflict began on October 29th and
almost immediately things started going
wrong far from keeping the Canal open
the anglo-french forces were unable to
prevent the Egyptians from sinking
derelict ships filled with concrete into
it making it impossible to shipping
making things worse Egypt's allies
declared an oil embargo and Syrian
Engineers sabotaged a British pipeline
between Iraq and Lebanon leaving the
warring Nations star for oil if they
were hoping to get help from their Chief
Ally the United States they were sorely
disappointed President Eisenhower was
outraged by the events angry that his
allies had gone behind his back and
launched a war of aggression that risked
Soviet intervention and the possibility
of a third world war this time with
nuclear weapons he famously said that
the combatants could boil in their own
oil this was the first major test for
the United Nations since hammershal had
assumed leadership of it and the
secretary-general responded assuming a
leading role in managing the crisis the
general assembly called on him to enact
their resolution calling for an
immediate ceasefire on all sides to
enforce it how much gold on the advice
of Lester Mike Pearson future Canadian
Prime Minister oversaw the creation of
the United Nations emergency Force
troops under the banner of the UN who
weren't there to fight a war but to keep
the warring Nations apart this was an
entirely new idea one that would prove
revolutionary in the decades to follow
to distinguish the peacekeepers from the
combatant troops the idea was concede
for them to wear blueberries but those
who would take time to make instead the
6 000 troops from seven countries that
oh would come to make up the unef would
dunk their helmets in blue paint
creating a distinctive look that
continues to this day the peacekeepers
gradually replaced the British and
French troops in the Canal Zone sending
them home while the UNIF Works to clear
the obstacles from the canal and keep
the enemy combat and separated meanwhile
U.N diplomats went to work eventually
convincing the Israelis to retreat
behind their ceasefire line in March
1957. Israel achieved one of their
primary War aims however when Egypt
agreed to end the blockade of the Gulf
of acaba which opened the Red Sea to
Israeli shipping it was the only success
any of the Triumph achieved before that
was particularly bad in Britain where
Eden resigned in disgrace NASA meanwhile
was seen as a hero in the Middle East an
Arab champion who had stood up to the
Old Colonial powers and won he would
lead Egypt until he died in 1970.
perhaps the biggest winner of the Suez
Crisis was the United Nations and darg
hamashkold he proved that the
international body would be able to
successfully mediate in a crisis to
prevent a small regional conflict from
becoming a major war for the emerging
Nations that were appearing in the wake
of decolonization they saw the UN as a
friend an organization capable of doing
them Justice this belief would be sorely
tested in the Years
foreign
for Africa when virtually the entire
continent was carved up into colonies by
the European powers in the late 19th
century has had consequences that
continued to the present day nowhere was
this scene clearer than in the Belgian
Congo originally a private Colony owned
by King Leopold II before being annexed
by the Belgian government in 1908.
unlike in other European colonies the
belgians did not even pretend to care
about the welfare of their colonial
subjects as Belgium companies grew Rich
from mining the Abundant natural
resources in the Congo the caste system
similar to South African apartheid was
in place that saw belgians in charge of
everything in the country and restricted
the Congolese to subordinate positions
there were no native born army officers
doctors and barely any University
graduates why Belgium ran everything
made all the money and lived and
caroused in separate neighborhoods and
entertainment districts from the
indigenous people on June 30th 1960 the
belgians rather abruptcy gave the
Congress Independence following years of
internal and external pressure to
colonize there have been no transition
period no gradual Handover of power from
the belgians to the Congolese no attempt
had been made to properly educate or
train the Congolese on how to run their
country they just left the new Congolese
government made up of men with almost no
political or administrative experience
now to try and figure out how to manage
one of the largest countries in Africa
all by themselves it was a recipe for
disaster The Crisis began less than a
week later on July the 5th when the
Congolese Army the ANC revolted after
their white Commander indicated that
nothing about the hierarchy was going to
change the Army Mutiny caused Panic
among the Y Community most of whom
immediately fled the country taking
their knowledge on how to run it with
them on July the 9th Belgium sent in
thousands of its troops without
consulting the Congolese government
claiming they needed to protect lives
and property they mostly congregated in
the Southeast and katanga province whose
leader moistombe declared on July the
11th that katanga was seceding from the
rest of the Congo the intention o is now
clear katanga possessed most of the
mineral wealth of the Congo representing
an estimated 50 of its annual GDP and to
schomber had no intention of sharing it
with the rest of the country Belgium
which I precipitated the crisis now was
taking advantage of it to try and keep
as much of that wealth for themselves as
possible with the country teetering on
the edge of Civil War the UN and its
diplomatic Miracle Worker dark hamesh
gold oh I called in to try and save the
day
immediately plans were drawn up for a
U.N Force like the one that had been
deployed during the Suez Crisis to order
the Belgian troops out of the country
and keep the situation from
deteriorating any further hamesh gold
feared that if the Congo collapsed into
civil conflict many of the surrounding
countries with similarly fragile
government would follow until the entire
region went up in Flames but it soon
became clear this wasn't going to be
like the Suez situation at all the
Congolese prime minister Patrice lumumba
are wanted the U.N troops placed under
government control so that he could use
them to crush the katangi's secession by
force hamishgoal flatly refused saying
that his troops were there to stop a war
not to start one lumumba a fierce
Nationalist and anti-colonialist then
threatened to ask for military help from
the Soviet Union he saw hammershal's
refusal to help him as a sign that he
was in the pocket of the imperialist
West the already delicate situation was
made worse by behind the scene meddlings
from foreign spies in subsequent decades
it would come to light the Western
intelligence agencies in particular the
Americans and the belgians had been
working covertly to manipulate the
situation in the Congo to their
advantage the Congo was of great
strategic interest to the U.S for one
thing most of the uranium used in the
Manhattan Project had come from mines in
the country and of course Cold War games
were being played as the U.S and the
Soviet Union jockeyed for an influence
in the Congo while the interests of
native citizens were barely considered
at all propped up by the CIA the new
head of the ANC Joseph Desiree mabutu
declared a coup in September taking over
the country and dismissing both lumumba
and President Joseph kasabubu it was a
cynical Cold War calculation La Mumba
always seen as two left-wing and he had
to go while cassava boo who favored the
West was eventually restored to his
position now there were four governments
in the Congo all claiming to be
legitimate cassava Boo's government in
the capital leopoldville today called
Kinshasa the katangi succession under
shashombe in the Southeast another
secessionist government in South Kasai
Province and in the Northeast at
Stanleyville today kissing gani were
supporters of lumumba even though the
man himself was effectively under house
arrest in leopoldville protected from
abuju's troops by U.N peacekeepers it
was in this increasingly complex and
confusing environment that dark Hamish
gold and his Congo Club of diplomats
attempted to keep the lid on a pot that
was dangerously close to boiling over he
put pressure on Belgium to withdraw its
Army which it eventually did only for it
to be replaced by an army of mercenaries
many of whom came from France or Belgium
and were violently right-wing and white
nationalist the CIA meanwhile was
plotting to assassinate Patrice lumumba
convinced he was still a threat to turn
the country over to the Soviet side the
only reason that this failed was because
lumumba's other enemies got to him first
attempting to break out of his house
arrest lumumba was arrested on the 1st
of December by baboutu's troops he was
imprisoned and regularly beaten until
six weeks later mabutu and cassava boo
handed him over to Moyes to chambe and
katanga who hated him Patrice lemon but
who might have become a great Statesman
like NASA had he been given the time to
mature as a politician instead became a
martyr executed by December's Belgium
officers at the age of 35.
Hamish gold was blamed for the death of
lumumba and for the deterioration of the
situation in the Congo by the Soviet
leader Nikita Khrushchev and their U.N
delegation Khrushchev denounced
tamashkold on the floor of the general
assembly accusing him of everything from
incompetence to corruption and demanded
his resignation his reasoning always
entirely political he wanted to do away
with the position of Secretary General
entirely replacing it with a three-man
Troika with representatives from western
eastern and non-allied or emerging
Nations each with an automatic veto over
the others how much gold defended
himself against these allegations
refusing to resign he was buoyed by the
support he received from the rest of the
world he had been unanimously re-elected
to a second term in 1958 and was still
immensely popular all over the world the
Congo crisis still churned on though
officially the UN was not on anyone's
side in the conflict but it did have a
mandate to detain and Deport foreign
mercenaries or wherever it found them
and since katanga's Army was heavily
supplemented by mercenaries including
most of its officer Corps de chambe
viewed the United Nations operation in
the Congo onuc as enemy in September
1961 U.N commission is on the ground and
the Congo decided to Embark upon a major
operation to round up mercenaries in
katanga ahead of the arrival of Hamish
gold who was flying into the Congo to
attempt to mediate and expect a
negotiation between the disparate
factions crucially the exercise code
named Operation more Thor was conducted
without Hamish Gold's prior knowledge or
approval and was begun while he was
flying across the Atlantic out of
contact instead of a peaceful detainment
of mercenaries the U.N troops found
themselves in an eight-day shooting War
oh with the katanganese who are resisted
violently 30 new and blue helmets and
around 200 katanganese troops were
killed in the fighting while over 150
Irish troops were forced to surrender
after running out of ammunition in the
town of jaderville a major embarrassment
for the UN how much gold arrived in the
Congo to find the situation had gone
wild and immediately set about restoring
order his first order of business I was
a face-to-face meeting with moist who
had fled across the border to Northern
Rhodesia today Zambia to negotiate a
ceasefire between katangus troops and
the U.N on September 17 1971 how much
gold and 15 others left leopoldville
aboard a dc-6 aircraft the U.N was
leasing called the Albertina flying to
the Rhodesian city of nadola this was
where the meeting was going to take
place a craft was last heard from just
after midnight on the 18th when it was
coming in for landing at nadola airport
but never made it at 3 P.M the next
afternoon the remains of the plane were
found eight miles from the airport only
one man was found alive a soldier who
was part of the security detail for the
Secretary General but he died five days
after the crash in an instant Dark
hammershkold Age 56 was gone
[Music]
the shocking death of the un's leader
touched off a wave of mourning around
the world how much Gold's body was flown
to Sweden where he was given a state
funeral attended by the king and queen
of Sweden as well as heads of states and
other dignitaries tributes poureden the
greatest of which was two months after
his death the awarding of the Nobel
Peace Prize to date the only posthumous
awarding of the honor of all the
compliments paid to him perhaps none was
more poignant than that paid by
President John F Kennedy who said of
Amish gold I realize now that in
comparison to him I am a small man he
was the greatest Statesman of our
Century initial fears of a similar
crisis that had precipitated how much
Gold's own appointment were unfounded
Burmese Diplomat youthand was elected
relatively easily to replace his friend
he managed to bring an end to the
katanga crisis in January 1963 but the
Congo continued to be embroiled in chaos
especially after U.N peacekeepers left
in 1964. ultimately Joseph tasir emabutu
stage a second coup this time installing
himself as a dictator renaming the
country Zaire the newly URI star babutu
cesico would rule the country until he
was deposed in 1997. today called the
Democratic Republic of the Congo it is
one of the world's poorest Nations
ranking low on most economic and human
development indexes and it continues to
be subject to internal conflict and
political corruption almost from the
moment the remains of the Albertina were
discovered there has been speculation
that the crash of Hamish Gold's plane
wasn't an accident official
investigations conducted by the
Rhodesian government and the U.N cited
pilot era as the cause of the crash
likely the result of the plane's crew
flying at night to an airport they
weren't familiar with having to send it
too low crashing into a hill that was
recently discovered to not be indicated
on their Landing charts of nadola
airport but how much gold had no
shortage of enemies in the region the
katanga government hated him so did the
European mercenaries fighting on
katanga's behalf and some have even
accused The American or Belgian
government of being behind the Downing
of the plane Witnesses have come forward
claiming to have seen the plane shot
down by a fighter jet or that the plane
suffered an explosion or fire before
crashing but to date no conclusive
evidence proving assassination has been
brought to light and the more time that
goes by the less likely it seems
ever will
dark how much gold is considered all one
of the best secretary generals of the
United Nations that has ever been he
took the fledgling U.N and helped bring
it to maturity on the international
stage shepherding it through some of its
earliest crises during the height of the
Cold War most important of all he
inspired a card rare Diplomat who were
committed to the idea of the UN and
after his death they continued to grow
the organization in both size and
influence deploying troops under U.N
sanctions as peacekeepers has continued
in the decades since Hamish Gold's death
with varying levels of success but
today's un goes beyond conflict
resolution between nations it is on the
front lines of international attempts to
stop human misery of all kinds from
property to disease to Disaster Response
how much Gold's fingerprints are all
over the modern U.N from the
organization's Library named after him
to the dark Hamish gold medal awarded to
anyone who gives their lives during a un
peacekeeping operation it's hard to
quantify a man who sacrificed so much in
the name of Peace but it can safely be
said that the world is a much better
place for having had dark Hamish gold in
it something that we should all aspire
to